من جديد مخيم جنين يتحولوا الى ايقونه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه خلال تصديه للعمليه
الاسرائيليه الاكبر منذ عشرين عاما عمليه
تسببت بتهجير الاف العائله واستشهاد
واصابه عشرات الفلسطينيين بالاضافه الى
مقتل جندي اسرائيلي واصابه اخرين فلماذا
يحدث كل هذا في جنين راحنا المخيم روحنا
حياتنا كل شيء لنا يعني عشان يضلوا شامخ
وواثف
وما زال
مخيم جنين او عشو الدبابير كما يسميه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لطالم شكل مصدر صداع
دائم له ومنذ بدايه هذا العام واجهت جنين
اكثر من 20 عمليه عسكريه ودائما ما كانت
تدفع الحصيله الاكبر من الشهداء من بين
مناطق الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]
مساحه المخيم لا تتجاوز نصف كيلو متر مربع
ويسكنه 14 الف فلسطيني يعيشون ظروفا
اقتصاديه صعبه معظمهم من الذين نجروا من
القرى والبلدات المجاوره التي احتلت عام
عام 2002 تعرض المخيم لحصار استمر عشره
ايام قتل فيه الاحتلال عشرات الفلسطينيين
ودمروا جزءا كبيرا من المخيم كما منعت
سيارات الاسعاف من الدخول اليه لكن
المقاومين تصدوا انذاك لاحتلال بشراسه
وقتلوا اكثر من 20 جنديا اسرائيليا
حين اطلق عليه الرئيس الراحل ياسر عرفات
جنين جراند تشبيها له بحصار مدينه
الروسيه التي صمدت طويلا في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
وفي الاونه الاخيره شاهد المخيم ولاده
مجموعات مقاومه جديده على راسها كتيبه
جنين كما انطلقت منه عمليات عند ضربه
اسرائيل على ارض جنين استشهد الشيخ عز
الدين القسام الذي قدم من سوريا مع رفاقه
بعد قوله معركه مع الانجليز وعلى اطراف
مخيم اغتيلت الزميله شيرين ابو عاطف العام
الماضي برصاص جندي اسرائيلي خلال تغطيتها
للاحداث
اكبر من مجرد مخيم وكلما حاول الاحتلال
ضربه جزوه المقاومه في عادت من جديد هذا
ما يحدث كل مره وهذا ما جرى خلال العقدين
الماضي